Brazilian President giant ball Senora
says he has tested positive for
coronavirus he made the announcement on
Brazilian television in the last hour he
had been showing symptoms of coughing 19
including a fever but said he felt well
enough to walk around a simple scenario
has drawn criticism from public health
officials for appearing in public
without a protective facemask and for
saying it was not worth the effort to
prevent the majority of brazil's
population from contracting covered 19
let's join journalist and matias a Ebert
in a Rio de Janeiro for more are welcome
Matias so the president says he's fine
do we have any further details about his
condition he said that since yesterday
he's am suffering some pain general pain
in his muscles and he has fever and he
also has a dry cough so he's not in a
really good mood but he's um yeah
getting back and staying at home now in
these days and waiting for the result
which now resulted positive and so he
cancelled the meetings for today and
possibly also for the next days because
he might now stay in care in time so now
we're seeing pictures of him wearing a
face mask he's changed his attitude to
that is he likely to change his stance
on the pandemic itself this is really
not sure if he will Stan who will change
his opinion on on the on the wiser
virus crisis um it could happen that he
will act from now on as it happened in
the UK a for Boris Johnson and who also
changed his mind a bit and and changed
his politics and his policy after have
him having suffered the the kovat 19 and
my virus so M it can happen like this
but it calls can also happen that ball
so now we stay at the same point will
want economy to come back so it's not
sure so far if he will be if there will
be
a new mindset for him okay so Brazil at
the moment then has I think a temporary
Health Minister while this crisis is
going on and now a president who's
possibly in take the next few days off
to take care of himself who's going to
be running the country
normally button arrow should at least
say fourteen days at home and his
Prudential palace in Brasilia and then
the vice president and morale will take
over and this also already happened last
year when Watson narrow had to go for a
surgery to hospital in Sao Paulo and
morale then will take the lead will
maybe possibly travel and in Brazil and
so it is a common situation for
Brazilians it's typical for them it's
not a big issue but we will see how
what's now really react in the next
day's he was the one who who put
pressure in order to get back to normal
life restaurants are open shopping
centers are open again and so yeah the
numbers are still high so it's really
not sure how Brazil will go into the
next days okay Mateus a but in Rio de
Janeiro thank you